today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza and in gray block if
you like different styles of pizza you
can do it they got playing onion garlic
poppy they got different sauces basil
pesto olive pesto pink alfredo and they
got all type of special toppings
barbecue marinated chicken parmesan
mozzarella gorgonzola goat Gouda fada
they got all the cheese's all the good
stuff ground beef
black forest ham whoo mysterious but
still ham
they got button mushrooms pineapple
leeks cilantro garlic and countless
other items sauces and styles gray block
pizza in Santa Monica check them out
online gray block pizza calm 18:11 Pico
Boulevard on the way to the beach gray
block get that hitter Amen baby
amen and B men to a lot of second level
dudes out there a lot of B men as well
you know that you know who you are
remember ladies night remember that
ladies night uh it's ladies night that
was always I feel like the biggest crock
of [ __ ] you know look dude it's ladies
night I would always have a friend and
not even a friend sometimes just an
enemy that are just a but someone I knew
that drank and could walk to a to a bar
any book oh boy it is night ladies night
over there
it's ladies night dude down at the smoke
and onion bro you wear you out like dude
come on man we ain't getting no ladies
bruh you ain't getting no ladies buddy
dude every time we go out we get zero
ladies you think tonight with the D that
oper that you think tonight something's
going to be different that the arm that
the cou that the cooter fairy is just
gonna come and hit us with that cooter
wand or something no you can't you got
to recognize that you know it's Lee come
on bro
slightly use night man come on
do you know good and well if you and me
are in it man it ain't down a ladies
night bro it's gonna be you and me are
gonna get there we're gonna pay that
cover and they always put like a lady by
the door so it looks like those ladies
and they make you wait in the line you
get in there and they got one lady
there's just the coat lady she's taking
people's coats and we live in Louisiana
do you know nobody has a damn coat so
that's really waste of fixed cost right
there that I mean that lady's just doing
nothing sometimes you'll see somebody as
a tank top you know if somebody wore a
double tank in there and they shed one
and give it to the girl
keep her employed you know keep a little
Tiffany employed our little Daphne or
whatever you know named after somebody
who doesn't know how to pronounce
flowers you know Daphne dales but man I
it's late come on dude it ain't broke
when we go we've been going places for
years man and niigata nobody's brother
we ain't got no ladies man he's the last
ladies night we went till I had to hold
your waist while you vomited because the
upheaval was too much for your body to
handle because you don't have a strong
spine man you know exactly what I'm
talking about so I'm just trying to be
honest man I'm just trying to be honest
and just do whatever I can or also do
whatever I can't you know that
all right let's kick this bad animal
right in the freaking ball bag you got
it
tie up your uh tie your own tubes you
know dude I used to know this tough girl
real real tough kind of girl man uh you
know she um she chose not to pass gas
sometimes cuz she liked to keep that
pressure in her body that kind of girl
like that's a real kind of girl just
snatch a damn goat off a bridge just
walk out you feel me the kind of girl
who would walk out on a windy day and
just take her damn breasts out and just
look mother nature right in the eyes and
say bring it on [ __ ] you know tough
girl and um oh [ __ ] I was gonna tell you
guys but uh let's get into this episode
of man like what I say
I used to know a tough girl bro it's
ladies come on boy it ain't
when you and me go Dawg it ain't I ain't
man dude it ain't never look you got
beat up number one time we were walking
to a place me and my buddy and he got
beat up by the dude with the arm
we went going to a happy hour he got
beat up with a by a brother with one of
those tacks guy signs you know he got
beat up by a black Statue of Liberty
with a tax guy signed so it ain't never
ladies night man come on let's go all
right let's get into it
[Music]
national
huh
[Music]
why must we wait when we're alive it's
ladies night hello and thank you for
joining me
and joining yourself here and this is it
maybe this is it this is that cupcake
that life made us and I'll tell you be
honest with you right now there ain't
much frosting on that sugar piece right
now there ain't much frosting there
ain't much frosting on the dessert right
now is there
it's cake only baby and it's a lot of
bootleg cake a lot of bootleg cake we're
digesting right now you know you are you
know I went for a jog here's one thing
that's just really boiling boiling my
beef and I mean when I mean boiling my
beef is when I'm going for a jog and a
jog you know it's you know you want to
run but you you can't run because you
were not that fast so you jog
it's basically what white people started
doing because we you know we wanted that
when when black people started running
we were like aw [ __ ] we're not running
we're kind of jogging so let's rename it
and so that's how that really shook down
to be factual or historical you know
because black people were fast man I
mean they had what was it they used to
they used to have the UM the R
Underground Railroad bro if you went on
that that's where Carl Lewis came from
the R Underground Railroad dog you just
go down there you'd have a white dude
had to get in a train just even keep up
with the black guys on that thing so
there's a lot of speed coming out of the
black community in the eighteen
hundred's early 1900s but oh here what
I'm noticing is I'll go for a jog right
or what I call a white run and I'll go
for that really you know I'll go for a
white run and I'm passing other joggers
you know constituents you know foot
constituents and they don't wave and
that just B's my B okay
boils my beef buddy if I'm running and
you are also running and we pass by each
other and you know why you don't wave
we're in a pandemic this could be the
end of time you know this might have
been when Mother Nature set her alarm
and you're not even just you're I'm out
here doing my best you're doing your
best you're not gonna give me a Hello a
peace a thumb up give me a thumb up man
it gets me because especially if you're
doing Fitness if you're doubt there you
know I get out there I'm doing full body
fitness I'm running keeping my chest
forward when I run try not to arch my
back too much you know I don't want them
gay dudes flexing cuz you in in you know
this is Los Angeles man this is really
this is um you know this is a hotbed
really for homosexuality an adult gay so
you if you're running with and you're a
male and makes in a lot of these men see
you they want it and that's nature man
that's not and there's no judgment there
that's nature it's like say if you are
if you like you know you know burgers or
snacks you could get drive-through meals
say you like drive-through meals and
you're walking somewhere and somebody
throws a cheeseburger right in front of
you I guarantee you might not reach for
that [ __ ] but you're gonna follow it
with your eyes and see where it lands
and then you're gonna consider things
and maybe make a choice
but [ __ ] once I talking about dude um oh
yeah
you got to be careful a lot of men out
there if you go running but anyway if
I'm running and I jogged past someone
and they don't acknowledge that's what
it gets me you know that just gets my
damn gander
it just gets my Gander in a Gandalf boy
and just God God dang it
okay like what your what we I just went
a mile bro
you just win a mile you're not gonna hey
and that's the kind of [ __ ] makes me
question how we're doing how we're doing
as a specie you know and I see some man
I'll tell you this I see a lot of fast
Asians out there a lot of FAS and and
they don't touch the ground when they
run you see of Asian it really they they
what they run like the world is hot like
the you know they run kind of their legs
are a little bit they're uh they always
run at the stoplight a lot of Asians of
those people they will continue running
to stop like they don't stop I'll stop I
push the button you know a fist bump the
homeless dude that's there you know I
mean give him a couple coins couple you
know dime pieces or whatever a couple
ten pieces but age and they know they
just keep they're ready to rock um so
yeah though you know that's been
something I've been dealing with when
I've been doing a lot of miles in the
area and I've been running I've been
running and it feels good I kind of got
started to get a little bit out of my
comfort zone you know cuz your comfort
zone man can really can really be your
coffin and and so I used to only run two
miles and I hated it I hated every step
I hated the beginning of the run I hate
at the end I hated arm
part between the beginning in the end so
all of it
and when I start when I when I uh
but one day I said you know what I'm
gonna run I had a little bit extra
energy and energy is just that that's
that it's just that it's kind of when
God just says alright here you go bro
and hooks you up with some free [ __ ] you
know alright here you go bro here's a
little scoop of marmalade bro in your
heart not Go Go Go boy go and so I had a
lecture in is just I said I don't know
you know what I'm gonna take a different
route and when I changed my route that
really changed everything for me with
Ryan because suddenly it was a little
bit more of an adventure it wasn't the
same old same old
and next thing you know I'd go on like a
1/4 mile further so I'm doing time you
know I'm out there you know what I'm
saying I'm doing you know I'm doing time
like the future but I'm out there and
and so then the next time I ran I said
oh man I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna go
do that new Trek again now it was
exciting to me and then next thing you
know I said oh you know what I'm gonna
go two and a half miles I'm doing two in
the core I'll do two and a half bro
you know I burn another quarter of this
bad [ __ ] you know I'll serve another
slice of bad [ __ ] bacon to myself and
so next thing you know now I'm at two
and a half and now I'm like you know
what I'm gonna uh I'm gonna see how fast
I'm going I'm gonna keep time for myself
make it a little bit of a game make it a
little bit of a challenge or shalash
French challenge and so then then it
adds up and next thing you know I'm
running and I'm doing three mile three
and a half brah three and a quarter
stars yeah so there anyway that's been
my adventure that's been my experience
in my adventure with running and now you
know I'll go do three and three-quarter
miles I did it today I walked the last
three quarter miles though because I
just got it like had like a attitude
kind of a little bit of a kind of
another meltdown but like a
just they had a [ __ ] homeless dude
and he was shadowboxing over by the
interstate and I jog right by the
interstate bro
cuz that's who I am some people jog safe
areas bruh [ __ ] that dude I want to be
by the interstate I want to hear a van
going by you know I'm gonna hear that
[ __ ] going right by my ear I'm gonna be
able to hear somebody inside a van
inside a shitty van
I want to hear two kids two fat kids in
the back of a shitty van sipping a
Shasta that's how close I want that van
to be you know I like to be right on the
edge because I run five you know I'll
run faster I feel like if I know that
that uh that the Grim Reaper kind of has
one eye on me you know and I've always
been like that
but yeah so anyway I like to run out
there in this dude they had a I don't
want to say homeless but this guy was
definitely you know covered in dirt and
looked like he didn't know where his
parents were at and he was probably 38
so you know he could have been armed he
could have been no he couldn't have he
yeah well this homeless guy anyway he's
out there shadowboxing and it looked
like he had shadowbox under some real
under some good trainers you know it
looked like maybe Tony Jefferies or
something had you know had trained him
at one point like the guy had some
skills so I had to go even further
around and I got pissed and then at one
point he threw a glass item at me and so
that [ __ ] made me I I felt like I needed
to be a little bit more on alert so
that's when I shut the rundown and just
went into a little bit more of defense
mode and just kind of kept my eye on the
premises in the area while went by
because there's a lot of homeless are
stacking up around me
it's getting pretty stachy in the in the
vagrancy Department out here
but anyway it's ladies night
hey you get in there there's like some
draw girl and she she's like oh she's
hooking up with the bartender she won't
shut up I'm Osama jr. and you're like
damn I just want to buy this [ __ ] a
hot air balloon and fill the tank up
with fricking weed gasoline and launch
that Gatch you know out over the ocean
let's see what God wants to do but thank
you guys thank you guys for supporting
me I hope you having a good week you
know I was dealing with some depression
honestly man this past weekend uh
something trying to find my way out of
that funk you know I hate uh I hate
feeling like that and I hate sometimes
and I'm you know I'm not trying to you
know I just hate feeling like that man I
hate it when I feel that way but I'm
learning to be a little less hard on
myself and just say you know sometimes
not every moment is gonna be you know
not every moment is gonna be a
mountaintop you know and sometimes
you're gonna be you're gonna feel low
down and you're gonna feel like this
something like somebody's just like just
like the world just has a shovel and it
just keeps hitting you in the head
because you you feel so low in the dirt
so yeah I've been trying to just get out
of some of that and so that's why I try
to do a little bit more running you know
I'm just trying to take care of myself
sometimes it's hard it's hard for me to
want to take care of myself it's hard
man it's hard and I don't even know why
sometimes why you know God gives me so
many gifts so many you know blessings in
my life and and and I still don't
l don't want to sometimes you know take
care of myself I don't want to do what's
best for me I want to be you know I want
to be lazier I want to be you don't want
to dance you know just not take care of
myself just not do you know I want to
sulk I want to be mmm what is it called
I'm gonna have self-pity you know I want
to do all of that instead and that's how
I know you know depression is a real
thing and anxiety that kind of stuff
it's a writ that that's real stuff you
know and that's and that is some of that
some of the dark arts and we've been
saying that and I don't know a lot of
people are going through that you know
there's a lot of time that we you know
we're just by ourselves me do my couch
if you look at Mike out of that could
the my couch has one big-ass cushion you
know cuz it costs extra if you want to
you want to cut that cushion into three
pieces it costs extra if you want it cut
you know that's like when I used to work
over there BJ's Pizza over there by
Claiborne Hill and they say all right we
want that large we want that large meat
because that's what we had large we had
meat and non meat those were to me those
were our lead pies and they said all
right and then for 60 cents extra we'll
cut that [ __ ]
but if you do but if you're trying to
save money if you cut in corners and we
ain't cutting that pie baby so but yeah
you know anyway I'm not trying to Dell
I'm not trying to dwell but yeah you
know my cut my sofa look like mean damn
that thing looked like you ever see a
picture of the ocean when they say the
ocean if it's empty or what it looks
like at the bottom I saw my sofa cushion
is starting to look like that thing has
been in a damn gangbang with my fat ass
and it is it has not been winning so
yeah just trying to stay motivated and
get moving
and just get my feet moving and doing
the things I know talking to friends and
not isolating you know my when I start
feeling depressed man its isolation is
what I want to do but it's not what
really helps me and then and when I feel
depressed man I can't see my blessings I
can't see the good things that are out
there looking for me cuz the Lord
through a lot of chocolates out in my
life man and these [ __ ] are looking
for me and I'm not talking about sisters
but I'm talking about real you know just
sweet options you know there's a lot of
if I want to see the good it's always
there it's just a matter if I really
want to look for it or not or not even
if I really want to look for it just if
I want to see it for what it is anyway
I'm kind of rambling but I'm just you
know I know some people are probably
struggling right now and uh and I'm
trying to be a leader for myself I was
you know I was thinking my leadership
and I'm just man sometimes it's hard to
be
you know it's a it sucks sometimes when
your wrist when you were responsible for
yourself sometimes this sucks
like damn can't you know sometimes I
want to wish that we were all lived in
some matrix or matriarch matriarch or
something where something's controlling
all of us just so it wasn't my
responsibility
you know I don't want my life sometimes
I don't want my life to be my
responsibility sometimes and it used to
be all the time for me man when I was
when I was younger but I said damn I
didn't want I didn't want a last thing I
wanted to do is be responsible for
myself but you know we do you know I've
been trying to do the things that are
different you know I've been trying to
take action and and be grateful and do
things like that so that's where we are
and that's where we are today and I'm
grateful for you guys we got a lot of
nice calls on that came into the hotline
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three and and you know we had you
know I wanted to see about crime out
there because when you know you know a
lot of crime and I almost got hit by a
dam you know uh a homeless guys slinging
glass out there and homeless dude you
don't know what they'll break out
whatever that dude you know what I'm
saying you bring a knife to a damn
lawnmower fight or he'll break out a
side of a boat like ma'am this guy he's
got about to beat my ass where today I'm
uh you know what uh starboard said they
could they're playing on a different
ball field you know you bring a baseball
and he'll bring a [ __ ] nom you know
he'll bring to our escalator stairs like
damn this guy this dude named flame man
he's about to beat the up-down out of me
bruh this guy's about to beat the day
I'm up down out of me um we had some
calls that came in I wanted to hear how
different places in the world were
dealing with and and in in in what your
what your corona was like your corona
time and so we got some calls that came
in here right here
this is Nicole from Malaysia and
beautiful place over there Malaysia and
ice actually saw a couple of monkeys
over there steal a bag of chips from a
thick thick urban chicken um and they
went at least two rounds but you thought
it was gonna end there but you know a
big girl don't wanna lose that's that
chip sac gang [ __ ] homeward hey Theo
it's Nicole calling from Penang Malaysia
hey Nicole and thank you for calling in
from Penang they're in Malaysia I don't
know I've been to Malaysia actually I
just told you that and it's a man it's
like the beach went to the beach that's
how that's how beachy it is and it is
it's humid you know I remember I took my
shirt off and they had two goldfish
swimming in my bellybutton I mean it's
that it's humid you'll find a damn
starfish come out from under yarn onward
internationally we're still in
quarantine over here and we probably
will be until the end of Ramadan which
is near the end of May because they're
real worried about people having large
gatherings for Ramadan since it's a
majority Muslim country shout out
Muslims brother shout out Slim's baby
all day home word so even though we
don't have a lot of cases at all we're
gonna be in lockdown for a while longer
which sucks and I'm a senior in high
school so we're all just hoping that
fill these up on the restrictions and
time for us to have graduation because
we really don't want to miss that it's
crazy here because it's actually illegal
to exercise outside so we can't run or
walk or dogs or bike outside at all and
I got stopped by the police for going on
a run by myself so you can't really be
outside at all unless you have evidence
that you're going to the grocery store
and that's the only time when one can be
outside so that kind of sucks because
we're really locked in here Wow
well thank you Nicole thanks for uh for
that message wow I can't believe you
guys are really I mean you can't even
take a dog yeah I guess you just have to
have a dog just teach a dog to what
urinate inside or use a toilet Wow
that's badass insane but um but that's
beautiful I'm glad that you know I'm
glad that that's that you know you guys
are able to I guess help the animals
like that but um yeah I mean that makes
me think at least I can go for a run you
know and why you can't exercise you got
stopped by the police for just for
fitness knew that reminds me one time I
was jogging in the Midwest and I was in
a real and that's the real thick belt
and if you've been to the Midwest but
damn you won't I mean you'll have a
thigh you know your Thyle just show up
out of nowhere they got a dam somebody
down you know you'll see a some felt I
got hamstrings with real ham on them
like boy that's a salty bass that's
salty backstrap um and I was going for a
jog and somebody stopped some guys like
um he pulled over he's like you okay
what's happening buddy all right
what's going on what another calmness
you know what are you running from man
you scared of something like nah man I'm
this fitness buddy
I'm doing I'm doing fitness I'm an adult
man but wow we're really putting
perspective and you to be in school and
not know if you'll be able to have that
graduation experience Wow hmm you know
that puts it into perspective for me for
sure you know we've got a lot to be
grateful for and you know I'm sorry I'm
sorry that you're dealing with that your
attitude seems really good though Nicole
I appreciate you sharing that with with
with me and and you know and just
sharing a little bit of what's going on
over there and then wow yeah if it comes
in a religious territory which I like
you know I like there being some
religion and you didn't sound negative
about it and I appreciate that you know
not that you would but you know I like I
think it's a good time for people to
have faith and and the fact that you
know people are gonna say okay not only
have I been going through this but that
doesn't negate that I'm gonna try and
still have my faith you know because if
I you know what I'm saying I've been a
half I've been one of those kind of
half-breed Christians you know well you
know you know my faith is always you
know I grew up I didn't really have a
lot you know how do I was around a lot
of it and we would go to church and
stuff but in my heart I didn't really
know much but so that's real special
that people are able to have faith and
and you know that they're not letting
that discount saying okay well look I
you know we did the core of it so now we
don't have to do you know we don't have
to do the fast and we don't have to do
this or that that's pretty powerful but
thank you thank you for that update from
from the Malay the Malay people over
there beautiful all right let's take
another call here and this is from prag
right here and this is Sean Hoffman
let's go Hotch hey this is Sean I'm in
Prague in the Czech Republic thank you
for calling Sean from Czech Republic and
when I actually visited there they had a
man pickpocketed me and this guy was
small this guy had the smallest damn
hands bro you couldn't even
I mean this guy oh no one you could
barely fit you know he could put dude he
could almost put both hands and both
feet in your pocket and you couldn't
feel it think about that think about
having four appendages in a damn pant
pocket and you can feel the person in
there and that's dark magic right there
let's hear more I wanted to see how
things wear elsewhere in the world
they're not knocked down for about six
weeks now things are slowly starting to
get back to normal as you can see it is
a whole bunch of other people out here
on the bridge still everybody wears
their masks outside but people are
starting to go back out to the parks
some of the stores are up and packed up
and I think by the middle of June things
might be yet getting back to being more
or less normal
looks like the borders gonna be closed
for the rest of the summer but maybe
after this is all done you can find
another European tour love to see you
gang thanks Sean interesting so yeah
that sounds pretty similar I think
things are starting to loop people
people are starting to loosen up make
the choice
some people you know and and that's what
life is like that is just a you know
it's a lot of just Hansel and Gretel and
that's who we are really we you know
we're curious creatures damn it I'm
sorry Sean but yeah you get that you
know people I noticed it too the
traffic's getting more in Los Angeles
people are doing more things more
thoughts trying to holler more gay dudes
even you know out here in LA there's a
thing now if you go running if you go
running on your feet and without a mask
that is a apparently it's like a pickup
thing for men that like other that like
other men and so it's like the new
member if you used to put your foot out
under the bathroom stall wall in
Minnesota or whatever you know you used
to drop that boot over there
that other dudes little [ __ ] and then
bang them next thing you know y'all
playing freaking hide that Rodney um but
what was uh but what I'm telling you is
or what I'm what I'm sharing right now
is just that yeah people are gonna make
their own choices and so I you know I
understand when some people are like we
need liber8 we need to you know I was
talking to my brother-in-law or
something I think you might be second
cousins or not second cousins but I
don't know Sumati [ __ ] somebody
honestly and that's how we're you know
cousin in law and he was saying well
like you have counties in Texas where
they had four cases of it so what do
those people do like they you know how
do they get back to work how do they
they can't start their universe back up
so it's tricky man is tricky to see but
I think humans you know we're gonna have
our own sense at a certain point of wins
okay to venture back out and get things
poppin enough you know feel the world
and know if it's safe and know if it's
safe for us and what our level would it
what's safe for me you know I'm risky
you know I'm that risky biscuit you know
what I'm saying you could put jam on me
bro you could put pepper you could put
down rubber cement on my back you know
what I'm saying
I'm still a snack dog so gang [ __ ] you
feel me but uh but thank you for sharing
this beautiful and if you and both uh
both of these call these last two
callers were from on video so if you
were watching on youtubes you can see
these peoples beautiful faces and and
and showing us from right here on a
famous bridge right there in Prague let
me see famous bridge in Prague and that
bridge is called the charles bridge
named after a white so beautiful man
thank you brother thank
for calling in and be safe over there
and and and yes definitely it's like
people's idea of what safe is different
people's idea of what's safe is
different I did read on that the there
are now 50,000 deaths in the u.s. from
corvid nineteen coronavirus and you and
every year the pneumonia gets that many
people as well every year pneumonia does
and I really believe that if we didn't
have if twenty years ago this happened I
don't think you would have heard
anything about it I really don't I don't
think you would have heard anything
about it I think it would have just been
like oh this year is a strong flu season
we have a flu that's lasted late and
that's I think that that's where it kind
of would have landed but now you have
the 24-hour news cycle so you got to
fill that news Bank you have to do it
there used to be two hours of news there
was morning news and there was evening
news and then they would do a late
evening in case she was by over you know
you had a little side piece over and
y'all wanted to do you know we'll look
at something before y'all went over
there and touched each other's bodies or
something or split a steak or something
but but now it's 24 so so they used to
be able to pack the whole news into
those three hours and some of the
stories would double over now there's 21
more hours of news so they got to fill
that with something and that's where I
think hysteria really began where the
news is like okay what can we do what's
and then at a certain point what's
selling for us what's keeping people
hooked on the screen so I really believe
that and and I really believe that if we
didn't have the 24-hour news cycle that
we wouldn't that this would just be kind
of a strong flu season that it came and
gone now I know that this is stronger
this has a ha this thing has a higher
kill rate than other than other flus but
but I just think it that's what it would
have been but hey what do I know right
and I might be wrong also so really good
chance of that let's take one more video
call that came in and this is gentleman
from Dubai right here gang what's up do
this is hunter checking in from Dubai
you not what's up honored thank you for
checking in brother from Dubai
onward lien American better live here
full-time now I just wanted to give you
some insight on what's going down in
this country it's pretty strict right
now we have handled it well and it's
been kind of contained to one is your
area the city I mean everywhere else is
doing pretty good but you have to apply
for a permit any time you go outside
anytime and now they've restricted it's
where you can only leave and go places
every three days so we're kind of just
huddled up hunkered down but shout out
to companies like cream and somato
that's like our version of posts mates
they're delivering the food still and
other than that device interesting it's
a definitely still kind of a third world
country scenario but pre kovat it was
very almost over employed there's
virtually no I want to
no homelessness see that though there is
a dark side these guys aren't these guys
from like Karachi Pakistan Dhaka
Bangladesh in various places like that
they're just they're not getting paid
well and it's rough living scenarios and
because of this and now they're just not
working at all so there's actually been
a spike in homelessness and people who
are stranded and the airports are closed
too they can't get back to their home
country so that is a sad thing to see
but other than that we're holding it
down thanks for everything you do Gang
Gang Green gang bro Thank You hunter for
that message man and that's information
as well as a message Wow yeah you don't
think of that you know I mean it's I
mean or you do think of it maybe you do
that the whole what you know it's in
every place it's it's going on and I'm
not trying it this isn't like a I'm not
trying to make this be a downer thing
I'm trying to just share what it's like
from around the globe you know you know
I'm not trying to make us feel bad about
anything I'm not trying to feel bad
about it you know this is what life is
life is
I mean life think about what life has
been for some people I think about some
man was born imagine this some man was
born somewhere in a forest maybe or you
know in like a dead like a like a thick
thick thick forest and he don't know
anything and he you know he grows up and
he doesn't his parents don't have much
money or whatever and he to say he does
woodworking he does basic stuff and then
he you know one day he sees maybe like
you know he sees like a beautiful bird
or something maybe you're robbing like a
Red Robin a red breasted
Robin and and that's like that's like
his the best part of his life and he and
then he dies and his family dies and and
that's his life his life with that one
thing when he saw that Robin it was
everything for him that was his that was
his you know having a family that was
his prom that was his you know getting
married that was his that was his that
was the that was it that was his his
life and that's a life that's a that
that's a beautiful life that's in its
own place the Robin man but it's
different when you get you know we're
used to like fancier lives getting to do
this and getting to do that and and now
some of that has just been adjusted but
thank you for that information from
there from Dubai and what it's like and
that while being stranded I would hate
that that would be tough man because
people gonna do what they're gonna do at
a certain point people want to buck
little Charlie gonna buck little Assad
gonna buck little yeehaw over here or
chin you know little chinstrap or
whatever your boys name is Viet people
gonna get bucked off somebody's gonna
[ __ ] hum a glass bottle at a jogger
you know the same people gonna start to
bend a little and see what they can do
you know also I wanted to know if there
was if if law enforcement how they were
dealing with some of the if there was a
spike in crime or what like that and we
had a well we had two officers that
called
I want to get one right here listen to
this VM right here okay here we go let's
get the fuzz on the line here what's up
video my name's Isaiah man you said any
officers of the wall
call in with your statements about the
domestics right now right now just
because of the covet and everything
going on
Thank You Isaiah thanks for your service
and thanks for and thanks for calling in
brother let's hear more and yeah man
it's been it's been crazy out here dude
I mean I think in the month of March
alone domestics where I'm from a devil
I'm in a Dayton Ohio area gang [ __ ]
Dayton baby then flyers huh what about
your boy Troutman I think he just got
drafted by the New Orleans Saints Blaine
you know it mm-hmm
and also if you've never been to the
United Air Force Museum I think it's
called in Dayton I would go out on a
limb to call it probably one of the top
six museums in America one of the top
six American museums or musaeus which is
Spanish let's hear more sir so we had a
domestic like a couple weeks back
homeboy sneaking out a fire escape
dude he gets down this fire escape
getting out and he's [ __ ] realizes
there's no ladder to take him from here
to there to the ground he just stuck up
there you know
shirtless he's got his shorts on he's
like [ __ ] man
we're standing in the alleyway hey man
you got nowhere to go
so you know that's just a little glimpse
of what it's like but uh appreciate you
man keep it up keep up the good work
take care thank you sir appreciate
appreciate the call yeah and that's real
I mean a lot of men stranded on the fire
escape aren't they all right I mean
that's just a euphemism for mayor of my
damn heart because that is just that
should be our national bird a shirtless
man on a fire escape with nowhere to go
I mean name a better one didn't think
you could
that [ __ ] mean yeah and two officers
down there like look buddy we might look
then jump then jump Bucer oniy okay jump
if you survived it I'll take you over
there to boot get of epidamnum
down by the south side down by the Dame
water and we'll buy you a freakin uh
pepperoni bread hmm but yeah that's
really Oh
that's how I feel that a lot of times
just feel shirtless and I feel like I'm
just on the fire escape of my own life
praise God brother thank you for that
sir and you guys stay safe out there but
yet domestics are going up the mess is
going up another day you know that she's
getting a hot you know it's getting hot
in the house a lot of spouses saying hey
uh honey will you turn the AC on it is
on okay it is on Ronald it's ladies
night it is on cut it on Jack
the AC is oh really Jane cos it's hot in
here
it sure is that's because we got two
hundred degrees of your [ __ ] and a
lot of these spotty ass ladies out there
too
being sneaky and being a little snack
attack those you know in text and
different men and stuff like this and
Facebook and they college heroes and
[ __ ] I'm telling you man these domestics
it's because you can't put if you put
too much fire and a furnace brush
something's going to get cooked
hmm and hey look I hate to say it but we
might end up with a few beautiful
episodes of Dateline out of all of this
and I don't want people to die but I do
want more Dateline and you just you know
that's you got to wonder how that'll all
work out all right let's hit the hot
line here nine eighty five six six four
nine five zero three and if you've been
if you've been having a relationship if
you think you know if you if you guys
have come to a conclusion that divorce
is the deal now for you and you think
it's because of the disease brother
that's in the air or in the nothing or
whatever in the water then hit us up and
let us know ninety five six six four
nine five zero three here's a call that
came in right here mister feel Vaughn
this is dog from Florida Oh what's up
Doug and you know them one of my early
friends man probably maybe one of my
first human friends this beautiful boy
named Doug Hugh ball and he had he I
mean this boy was just chiseled his head
was real chiseled like his head had been
working out like his head got up early
before he even woke up and went to the
damn gym and then came and got back on
his neck for breakfast you know kind of
that kind of boy and I met him in first
grade and he stuttered he had a stutter
something happened to him been hit by
something or you know or just how to you
know had that [ __ ] giddy a that
little hitch and his giddy and uh he had
that you know just something boy like
the Lord had just hit him in a damn neck
with uh with a 1x2 you know nothing
heavy but hearty enough to [ __ ] really
sting you know but his name was Doug
homeward Florida it's a great place to
get baptized and also fall into Satanism
oh yeah Florida's a great place man if
you like pyramid schemes and if you hope
one of your if you don't mind one of
your kids maybe getting
you know reach that by an adult a little
but they also got Busch Gardens so you
can't win them all baby but yeah a
little bit of Satanism bro gang brother
Homewood brother anyway man just like a
random coronavirus stop man dude I'm
miss shaking people's hands man I'm a
hand shaker I'm just a gentleman and I
want to walk up to another gentleman and
shake that [ __ ] hands
enthusiastically what do you think of a
world without a hand shaking dude
there's been talk of the Japanese bow I
think I'm gonna go with the military
salute much anyway man what's the future
looking like dude gang gang gang Doug
thank you man that's a good question
what does it look like what does the
future look like you know that who's
gonna do you know who's gonna be doing
what you know who you know what's it
gonna look like I seen a guy the other
day we have a Halloween mask on he's
over there looking like damn he's you
know Pokemon and he's be picking
avocados out it's unique man it's uh
yeah hands shake do I want it I like it
you know I like it we had a guy calling
in the past drippy mitts McGillicuddy
this beautiful fella this dude I think
his name might have been Steven maybe I
don't know I don't have the notes in
front of me in a beautiful young man and
he had those slippery fronts on his paws
you know he had the thing you couldn't
even shake his him because it was just
slipping in and out of you it would slip
in and I do how do you grip like a damn
eel like an eel eating frickin jelly or
Jam and it uh you know so hand shaking
the fist bump had kind of taken over a
little it's human touch
human touch it's it's disappearing man
it's been disappearance you know you're
trying to hook somebody not a key like
you a dang you know they you know it's
like a second-degree assault in our lair
you hug somebody they call it love
assault this place over here in
Hollyweird what do I want for the future
I like the bow I do think the bow is
pretty cool it's very kind of Nouveau
artsy you know it's a little bit of like
kind of a little bit of it okay okay you
know a little bit of Honor a little bit
of it's a lot of trust to with the bow
because you're taking your eyes off of
your opponent for a second when you look
down you know the handshake look in the
eyes the fist bump yeah it's the future
what do you guys think the future looks
like you think there's gonna be some
things in the future we're not thinking
of that could disappear or that could be
you know none that not that won't happen
anymore I personally think that we'll
just be taking people's temperatures at
places you know I think that that's not
a bad idea you know if somebody brings
their little kid a little freakin uh you
know Dylan or whatever his name is
little Darla or whatever little frickin
aw you know little freakness you know
little Ethan a little sneaky ass Ethan
bra and he that's the kind of kid he'll
pick his nose with all nine fingers brah
you know what I'm saying he'll pick his
nose till he pulls one of his eyes out
of it this little frickin behold and he
goes to the to the slip'n slot or
whatever to the UM kids gym Gymboree or
whatever that place over about a highway
for four for six dollars they'll let
your kid bounce around on a fishing net
with a couple of damn
beach balls on it or some you know but
they had what the hell am I talking
about I don't know man um but a lot of
places now they take a kid's temperature
oh and a lot of in a lot of countries
they take a temperature when you go
somewhere oh this kid's dirty get him
out of here
this kid hot get that a little hotter
get his hot ass out of here little Heath
oh that's a little hot Heath you know
what I'm saying here here's a little
sack ice or something put it in his
pockets and [ __ ] get his little ass
out of here
so I think you will see some stuff like
that what do you guys think you're gonna
see nine eighty five six six four nine
five zero three here's a call that came
in right here that stimulus check this
man homework would have been from
Baltimore and Baltimore they got a lot
of people on that methadone they got
people smoking methadone over there so
they got a lot of a lot of Krispy
wiggers out there doggone that methadone
gang [ __ ] homework haha way to work this
morning now during this whole time I'm
like I admitted to grocery stores of
Lumpkin school and everything so I do
work in this whole time and I wanna get
your thoughts on substance so this whole
time I thought this stimulus check [ __ ]
was a big hoax like I thought it was
like like once many promises like a
compliment started internet beef to try
to get the best society the like
panicking kind of calmed down that the
working stuff and then one day I'm like
explaining that everybody at my Duke
this was fake no one giving a [ __ ]
signal check one day I wake up I got
[ __ ] tribulus check so my thing is
though is this just Trump preying on my
generation and younger generations you
don't think about the future and are
very impulsive giving them mass amounts
of money that they're going to spend
immediately and not think about it
man you know I think at some point you
just got to be grateful you know you
can't think everything is a conspiracy
and look I appreciate your call man I
appreciate the call it's a good you know
there's a lot of things these days it
makes you wonder a lot of things make us
wonder you know it's just real what's
going on here what's really going on is
there a bigger thing that I can't see
here I love that I love thinking that
way but I don't want to think it's to a
level where I don't see the blessings
that are around me you know you got
$1,200 you got whatever it ever was 602
Stu you know you got a check you have a
government that gave you money maybe say
hey that's that's awesome I'm lucky to
be in this country where we are able to
do that you know everybody didn't get it
so you're really you're fortunate right
there you know I notice in my own
neighborhood they have there's a gym
that's near me and our community center
and they have campers outside all the
homeless people or a lot of them that
want that we're mentally able to not
live like in the rain or in the park
they put them in campers they came and
put them all in campers that's pretty
incredible to live in a country to live
in a place where that's where that's
something that's done you know I get mad
well you know like I try to support our
government no matter who they are you
know cuz I live pretty comfortably you
know I live pretty comfortably I live in
a place that has roads you know I live
in a place where there's clean water
clean enough that's coming out of my
faucet you know I live in a place where
if I'm struggling
so much there's someone close to me
probably a neighbor that could help you
know I live in a place where there's
entertainment usually I live in a place
where I can think I live in a place rock
I still go to the grocery you know I was
talking to a friend of mine from Russia
the other day she told me that her
parents do you have to apply to go into
the city every time you go in and you
then then whenever you get there you can
only go do the things you had said you
were going to do you know the gentleman
that called from Dubai you have to you
know I think he said you had to fill out
a form or something you want to go
certain place you can only go to the
market man there's a lot you know it's
so maybe just say hey you know yes the
earth is flat but this stimulus check
ain't boy so I wouldn't pay you know I
don't know if I mean yeah look into it
but don't look too far into it where you
don't recognize that that you were that
we're pretty fortunate you know we're
pretty fortunate man
[Music]
you know we just have so many blessings
man we have so many blessings I feel
like and you know gang bruh
alright let's take a another call here
what else had been going on not his
ladies night famous ladies night man
no it's dude it was never ladies night
man
oh do when I think back to some of them
I do I have hooked up with some real
hardy-har d7 & eights probably I'd say
eight usually because if a woman brought
as long as a woman will brush her teeth
all of her teeth to some ladies some
lazy-ass ladies just brush the tops oh
no miss that's why God gave you all the
teeth you got a wash them all and I'm
her when I was young my mother we had a
toothbrush and she wrote on it do all of
them cuz you know I get lazy I only want
to brush the tops and them chompers I
don't want to [ __ ] hit that support
staff at the bottom so um what's
something I was gonna talk to you about
that's been going on oh I started doing
piano practicing so pretty excited about
that
I've been doing duolingo yo entiendo mas
espanol I am understanding more Spanish
I've been doing duolingo man duolingo is
cool if you haven't ever seen it we
don't work for them or they don't they
don't work for us but I'll really like
it
what else hmm I'll see my going home
thinking about taking a trip home see
some family let's take a call right here
here we go hey Co this is hunter from up
here in northern British Columbia
ooh British Columbia dude thank you for
calling there from the UK my man gang
brother I was just listening to 17th
episode of your podcast this past
weekend and he said something about
wanting to bring the father to the
family that you were emancipated to to
the Masters because he was accessible
Gulf I don't know if that makes sense
but you wanted to take this man to the
Masters and he was the father of a
family that you apparently lived with a
little while you're younger but I just
was curious if you did that or if you
still claim I'm doing that and sworn to
let you know that you helped help a lot
of people including myself from love you
and your party man thanks oh thanks man
thanks for the nice words man uh I love
you too bro
gang um yeah actually one thing that you
know I didn't get to take we made the
plan this year to take my stepdad to the
Masters when I was 14 I went to live
with a friend of Mines family and they
had you know they had opened their doors
to me and so I went and lived over there
and and it was fun man they didn't have
any pets but they had some other
children and we really you know it was
just more of a safe and it was more of
an environment where there was more it
was just more emotionally comfortable
than the one I was in I just couldn't
survive I couldn't mentally survive in
my own house anymore and I don't know if
that really was to anyone's fault I
think it was just what my path was gonna
be and you know and I was gifted with
enough you know just I got you know
there were people they cared enough and
then
fighting me to live with them and we had
fun and the man has always been a good
role model for me and his name is Rhett
and he uh he is a adult and he he like
he loved golf and so for years I wanted
to take him to the Masters and you know
I had a good year last year work wise
and so I got us a trip we were gonna go
last week we're gonna go to the Masters
and we had a nice Airbnb and we were all
square
and this virus hit so you know I just
hope that he's you know and he had
started walking around the neighborhood
more and just getting ready to go and
and I'm glad you know for sometimes I
think oh man you know I don't know if
I'm gonna spend this money or I don't
want to but then once I've made the
decision to man it was I was so excited
and it was fun this went on Airbnb and
looking at places and asking friends and
you know when people wanted to help they
wanted to let me know what's a good
place to stay in a good area and we were
gonna have some fun but that's not going
to happen this year but when they
hopefully when they repost it up the
golf tournament then then we'll be able
to go so thank you for asking that was
sweet of you
yeah man when I think about so many
about the people in my life that have
cared about me man
a lot a lot of people
that's one you know sometimes it's like
man why you know why fun sometimes can't
find the why I can't care about myself
sometimes it just blows my mind
you know just why it's
why is it why is it just so hard to care
about yourself it's just so
sometimes it's just hard man but a thing
that does help though is thinking about
other people caring about me when you
think about the people that have cared
about you think about it
I think somebody used to give you a rod
or somewhere you needed you know
somebody who let you you you let you
borrow their car somebody who let you
borrow maybe a couple you know cut some
melon or a little bit of money you know
maybe some of these to write you letters
when you moved away or somebody that
that called you to tell you that they
loved you even you know even though you
had done something may be wrong to a
mutual friend of y'alls you know maybe
somebody who you maybe you put an error
in their shampoo you know 20 years ago
and maybe they still want to bang you
every now and then I mean it's just you
know there's a lot of love to be given
out there and a lot of it I get I've
been given a lot in my days man
so yeah thank you for asking about that
because just even you asking about that
just made me realize how much that even
in times when I didn't know how much I
cared about myself how much other people
cared about me man that's pretty
powerful huh it's pretty powerful to
think that love
such a weapon man is such a beauty is
such a such a just such a damn you know
you bring enough love to a life fight
and you can win every time you know it's
easy to get the other way that was so
easy to get the other way it's so easy
to just get on that down downhill but
gang bruh you know the other day I get a
FaceTime video call from my friend a
good friend of mine Scott Patrick is his
name also he has two names
that's his legal name and he's wearing
in his ears he's got all earbuds he
loves music he's a music man I mean he's
probably been to so many fish shows he's
he would test positive for uh for damn
bass meat in his body you know or uh
barramundi something tilapia at least
and he's got a pair of recon earbuds in
and he likes those because they help his
music the best he said whether you're
working from home or working on your
fitness you want what you're listening
to to be what you're listening to
not with your other friends or neighbors
or whoever else is listening to that's
why you need a great pair of wireless
earbuds you know you want something
that's gonna keep the sound in you and
take you to that second level but before
you go dropping hundreds of dollars on a
pair you need to check out the wireless
earbuds from Ray Khan support this past
weekend and check out these earbuds you
know recon you know ray con earbuds
started about half the price of any
other premium wireless earbuds on the
market come on now you know it and they
sound just as amazing as other top audio
brands that you know their newest model
the everyday II 25 earbud is the best
one yet
with six hours of playtime who you could
listen to at all you could listen to
that movie roots seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass and more compact
design that gives you a nice noise
isolating fit there's nothing that any
of us can't stand then having to listen
to something else somebody else they're
listening to um somebody teach Braille
or something in high volume and since
they got some garbage earbuds ee you're
having to hear it to get something
quality and that's what I'm telling you
about rake on now's the time to get the
latest and greatest from rake on get 15%
off your order at buy rake on come slash
Theo and that's a huge discount you need
your buds or your child needs them a
birthday coming up save that money save
that extra cash they're already cheaper
than other brands and now get 15% off
your order
at BU Y or a YCO in buy rake on comm
slash th EO that's buy rake on comm
slash th EO for 15% off rake on wireless
earbuds buy rake on comm slash Theo
support this past weekend it's lady
night in I'm feeling right you know if
it's ladies night or if it's Ladies Day
or what look sometime I put on a
brassiere and just I want to be a be a
little thick thick girl at the house you
know what I'm saying not really but you
feel me Doug what I'm talking about is
post mates if you're like me you
probably start thinking about what to
eat for dinner at about 7:00 a.m. yep
that's he had dude 7:00 a.m. a picture
of a beautiful beef Frank will pop into
my head or a sausage patty or uh you
know a London brawl and that's why I
love using post mates because come
dinnertime whoo
all I need to do is break out my phone
and get on the post mates app and order
what my heart has been thinking of how
and I love postmates even more right now
because you can get food delivered
without leaving the house
it's corvid approved you don't even the
door you could say look a little air is
set it out there Larry I'm gonna tip you
on the app set it out there
they created non-contact deliveries
that's right post mates it's all ready
you don't have to take the guesswork out
of you am I gonna get corvid they gonna
get corvid keep it clean baby so now
when you order from local restaurants
everything gets left right outside your
door they also have postmates to pick up
which I've been using order takeout for
my favorite local restaurants that's
right listen up you guys can support
this past weekend and you can support
your neighborhood spots right now I'm
only been ordering local order from
right down the street you know what I'm
saying Robin Diane's diner order from
over there little hair he's got the rib
Shak I do that give me some of Harry's
ribs bro but no hair on him you're
feeling me dawg I don't want those real
cheap ones if you get a real cheap rib
sometime gonna get a little bit of hair
at the end postmates doesn't just
deliver burgers and sushi they actually
make your life easier by picking up
everything you need from Walgreens
7-eleven and dropping it off outside
your door you didn't know that did you
well now you do support the podcast
download post mates on iOS or Android
find your favorites and get everything
you want delivered within the hour for a
limited time post mates is giving our
listeners $100 of free delivery credit
for your first 7 days so that means go
get your mama's phone get your cousin
phone get your little nephew phone get a
bit get the baby a phone and and get the
app and get them an email account and
open it up and get the $300 for a
limited time only post mates is giving
our listeners $100 of free delivery
credit for your first 7 days to start
your free deliveries download the app
and use code weekend
that's code weekend for $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
when you download the post mates app
anything you need
anytime you need it post made it use
code weekend thank you guys for the love
and the support yeah alright let's take
a call right here and see what's going
on right here this could be right along
the veins of what we're discussing gang
video you beautiful bastard this time
out of Indianapolis Indiana what's up
Tim over there in Indianapolis and uh I
saw somebody a group of white males hit
a dam hit some hit another thicker white
male on AB dang Birds scooter of it air
for Al I'm home word I just listened to
the pod man and Sergey say that love is
forgiveness and this really struck me
man is like out tree that really is I've
been with my wife now for almost 11
years with Mary for almost three three
and a half I think but the more the
story being man it without forgiveness
we wouldn't never made it this long you
know she's definitely forgiving me for
some of my stupid [ __ ] I have definitely
forgiven her for some of hers as well we
both went through a opiate addiction I
was both been clean for over six years a
member uh Amen doc onward which is kind
of unique you don't find a lot of
couples that actually make it through
the by the bout of addiction and then
get clean and come out the other side
and still be together
so she was definitely my other half man
and without without forgiveness bread
would never work cease love gang gang
gang Tim man thank you thank you for
that call yeah man it's it's really it's
uh you know even when I think back to
that family Tim that took me in then a
dude I was there I was there for a week
and I was doing doughnuts I had these
two beautiful lesbians that lived next
door across the street you know what I
was on watch
when I was a librarian or alleged
librarian and the other one was just um
was a lesbian and or you know just a
lesbian I think unemployed lesbian but
you know and you know I'm doing donuts
in her damn yard and an 84 Ford Escort
did with one of the windows that have
been broken out with by a damn handgun
and and yeah and this family I just
moved in with him and they forgave me
for that you know I did the first night
I moved in with the family that I lived
with in high school
I'm smoking weed in the bedroom it was
the first time I'd had a bedroom on my
own boy so I'm living it up dude you
know what I'm sayin bruh I'm [ __ ]
living life I'll put on some camouflage
dude I'll [ __ ] put on a little bit of
Cologne and I'm smoking weed doing what
I do you know celebrating and and yeah
and there are others their son their you
know their genital son or whatever it's
called he comes he knocks on the door me
like you what the [ __ ] are you doing in
here
I said manna nothing al I do I said
nothing me waters weed smoke everywhere
you know and I'm dressed like [ __ ]
Rambo like some kind of damn dope Rambo
and he's like dude you don't be doing
that [ __ ] man you can't be doing that
[ __ ] and he could have got me thrown out
I mean I just just moved in just crate
you know but when I think back to all
the things in my life that people have
forgiven me for it's crazy and all the
things that people still love me even
though I was greed here I was selfish
sure I was just a human ya know but
that's a beautiful story man and um and
thank you for sharing that with us and
thank you for you know I think being a
pillar of just
a reminder for people that if they're
struggling with addiction that you know
that I mean if they're struggling
addiction or marriage that they could do
both they could really beat both so a
membra gang man um what else we got here
dude whatever I've been doing dude been
on Facebook a little my facebook it's a
lot of people now just deejaying in
their basement if you don't notice this
everybody's a DJ now you know I see
Gerald or whatever you know snitch and
Ricky or whatever I snitch or whatever
you know what I'm saying MC [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I dude have no leg but he
gots a you know turntable so he can he
can move music but he can't move and
it's everybody you got a kid he's
[ __ ] doing a little bit he'll be
turning and a little bit of ariana
grande and in the samaa into some Def
Leppard he'll be crossing some tracks
and then beat his son at the same you
know the kid will come down dad I need
some milk you want some milk brah here
you go bro get that milky hand bruh and
get 2% of that hand son gang [ __ ] so a
lot of kids are really I mean think
about that child that memory as a child
all you remember is you couldn't go
outside they had disease allegedly
outside and your dad's a DJ and in a
basement for his high school friends so
is shit's shit's happening
we had another little officer of the law
that called in let's get that call here
hey yo this is Kyle what's up Kyle out
of st. Louis and st. Louis is famous for
the arch and also for this commedia is
up-and-coming comedian Chris D'Elia
actually has canceled they're doing it
show that let's hear more in my garage
and doing some prison yard workout
listen nothing turn off you're too fat
you
ya-ya-ya-ya-ya that prison your workout
that's nice to do by yourself
and not have to do an actual prison
where after the workout you got to watch
some guy bust out are you doing it you
know I'm saying you got to at least
stand there and look excited while
somebody jacks off so you don't get you
know abused or sexually abused gang
brawn work and you have to oppose the
question of law enforcement if the
message balance is up my girlfriend she
happens to be a police officer and she
said the numbers up to 25 to 35% in her
jurisdiction pretty crazy stuff I think
people need to get out get away from
each other she may killed me too I hope
not
we both love the show keep up the great
work be careful be safe Gang Gang Gang
bruh and thank you for your feet -
beautiful lady for her service Wow Dawg
yeah that's the thing you gotta get out
go take a drive take a bike get a
two-seater bike and cut the back off of
that [ __ ] and do a one-seater
you know get in a wheel barrow dog on a
downhill go be by yourself you know what
I'm saying live you got to take some
time play hide-and-go-seek have your
wife go count and you drive out of town
and get a motel somewhere I mean that's
easy
you have to just you know it has to be
you know you you got to separate from
each other it specially if you have a
weapon if you have a weapon buried a
weapon give it to your friend barri give
it to your friend bury the original
burying the weapon don't [ __ ] don't
you know you don't want to put a gun in
the dirt man you want to but good you
know have it somewhere else where you
can't use it if you want to shoot a
spouse you have to do you a handgun do
you know make a little gun with your
hand or draw a gun and throw it at them
you know draw it on a little sheet of
something though legal pad but thank you
for calling man I like that getting a
prison workout getting it done on your
own you know it's interesting I find
that I have to like I'm wondering like
Who I am is really coming into question
a lot with me during this
virus who I am you know am i just am I
only a guy who just isn't gonna you know
how much am I willing to take care of
myself how much man is in me you know
how much you know cannot be a leader for
myself I mean that's really scary to
admit sometimes and sometimes when I'm
in my depression I won't that's when I
don't want to be a leader for myself you
know wish somebody else had the controls
and that they were it's just and it's
such a lazy thing depression is also
such a there's a lazy edge to some of it
there's a self-pity edge to some of it I
find for myself I'm not talking about
everybody this is for me but I was
asking myself actually today what kind
of leader do I want to be even if I you
know if I'm just yeah because the only
person I'm really leading is me you know
I don't have a family you know yet and I
don't have an animal you don't have
animals that I see sometimes but that I
don't have like a day-to-day animal but
but I'm like what kind of Li what kind
of leader am i to myself you know what
kind of like leader am i to myself what
kind of leader and then if within if I
did have a family with my friends with
the people I work with and work and that
working are in our team here like what
kind of leader in MA
you know and do I have what it like how
can I you know it just you know and and
and to feel empowered to say I want you
don't want to lead I want to lead myself
to be better cuz then sometimes it
separates me from myself because
sometimes I I may not feel good you know
I don't want to go for a run I don't
want I did not want to go for a run but
then but then sometimes I can be a
Leanne say hey man you can go for a run
you know I'll be the leader of us I'm
not just gonna let my feelings because
my feelings sometimes are me and but my
choices are almost this other me and and
they and they my choices don't really
have a lot of feelings sometimes they
can just they can just do what's best
for me so even if I don't feel like it I
can go to my choices and say okay I know
you don't feel good man but let me be a
leader for you right now and let me
maybe just sounds like I have a split
personality disorder I don't know I
don't know what I'm talking about but
but it's just been interesting because I
feel like this is a time where a lot of
us are you know by ourselves or a lot of
us are you know things are more still in
some ways and so I'm sure a lot of
people were wondering who am I right now
to my family how how am I able to manage
my own vibe and my own tribe and and
keep things together and I just want to
let you know you can do it if you
struggle in wonder if you can be a good
leader for yourself and for others that
you can you can do it you know you can
and and and even if you haven't been in
the past
that's okay every day is a new
opportunity that's the beautiful thing
about days man
didn't have isn't that amazing isn't
that amazing that that today doesn't
remember yesterday like the actual day
what if the Sun rose and the first thing
it did was say hey [ __ ]
remember what you did on Todai but it
doesn't do that man the Sun just rises
and says hey man I'm I'm here for you
you know and I don't know I don't
remember anything you're like damn give
him give him Nisha Sun and the Sun was
like I don't know I don't know if I do
I'm just gonna be in the air for a
little while and then I'll be going man
but I'll see you tomorrow anyway I'm
rambling Oh what else let's get another
caller came in that came in here a call
is nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three hey yeah this is Austin
from Lynchburg Virginia what's up Austin
and it's a real sugary gentleman over
here calling there from Lynchburg in
Lynchburg Virginia that's where they
make that Lynchburg lemonade I think
homework I love your show man thank you
for doing it for us you're welcome man
thank you for calling and being a part
of this world gang so here's the deal
I've been in college for nine years man
oh dang bro Amen boy you might have got
caught up on a little bit of that D UST
you film his son and I've been there I'm
Rob bought a couple damn grams one time
first time ever that I purchased some a
little bit of dust you feel me a little
bit of that up and the man said he said
it was a performance-enhancing drug man
so I did a couple of straight bumps at
and [ __ ] ran about eight miles over
there near the railroad tracks over
there near in Baton Rouge Louisiana over
there off Perkins gang [ __ ] homework
three different schools honestly
and I've been through some [ __ ] trying
to graduate yes yes yes brother but it
sound like you they are now home word
well I'm finally graduating this man
like it's my year and they've canceled
my graduation mm-hmm
and I had invited all my friends and
family so I guess my question is this
and and Mike Pompeo was scheduled to
speak but since it's canceled
can you do my commencement speech I
would love to hear what you have to say
you give me some guidance so if you
could help me out man I'd appreciate it
getting gang all right bro let me think
so commencement this is the final
ceremony speech I'll try it
all right everyone good to be here today
and it's a beautiful day for everybody
here and I'm glad that everyone here
showed up even though it took some of
you guys nine years to graduate that's
absolutely unbelievable but also awesome
because you imagine being in college now
imagine staying in college for a lot
longer than you did
respect look I'll tell you this broad
the world is what it is man that thing's
a shapeshifter
you know when it's a dog it's a dolphin
it's a dart board and and so all you can
control is you and I know you're gonna
get out there and some of you guys are
gonna do drugs some of you guys are
gonna you know be gainfully employed
some of you guys are gonna probably
somebody in here is going to
statistically speak and somebody in here
is gonna probably hit somebody with a
vehicle and and leave the scene and get
away with it somebody in here will be a
murderer but no matter what you do
I think that I hope you feel some I hope
you put I hope you find time in your
life for other people and I hope that
you realize that life is yeah it's your
life but a lot of people care about it
not just you and so with that in your
mind and in your heart I hope that you
can you know treat your life as if it's
something nice that somebody you care
about let you borrow because in a little
bit of
way that's it's kind of what it is
somewhat you know when people care about
you you have some responsibility to care
about yourself
and I believe in you guys and I believe
you guys can do it do go acorns or
whatever the school spirit is man
gang [ __ ] bro good luck out there dog
and I Love You Man I'm glad you finally
graduated and and look there's always
opportunities for a party down the line
you can always do that later ah what
else I think I think we you know I think
we came to a good end here I think we
could finish up right here I um you know
I'm thinking about do one thing oh I'll
tell you this I was thinking the other
day when I was growing up dude a lot of
a lot of times at school we had this kid
named small Allen that went to our
school and he was small man he was I
mean you don't imagine somebody now just
imagine him being just real small and
that was him but uh now was him dude you
didn't I mean he he was just so tiny bro
so tiny his little elbows were tiny
sometimes he would use his elbows to do
uh
to need a bread or something he would
have to do that to knead a dough if you
wanted to knead a dough you had to he
had to use his elbows to get enough
pressure on it and we even someone even
a foot as well he was so tiny bro tiny
tiny and he had a he had a he was a
little a little nasty bro you know he
came from his daddy was nasty and so he
was also nasty he was like nasty jr. in
his in his DNA and he would do this
thing at school he would go in the
bathroom and turn the toilets
yuhh they had some nice whole school
toilets in there not even ceramic I
think concrete or even pewter nice
something quality
and he would cut he would turn the
toilets the plumbing off on him and if
kids had gone in the restroom and done
number two and this is a little vulgar
and I'm sorry to tell it but if they'd
done a number two you know a duty bra a
body duty he would then go in the
toilets wouldn't flush he he had this
big he had like this kind of I don't
want to say fetish because we were
children but he had this kind of dirty
desire to he would go Duty on top of it
you know what I'm saying like he like he
was the kind of person you ever walk
into a bathroom stall and if somebody's
already done a number two in there
somebody did a strong number two or even
a week number two and I'm like oh man
I'll go to a different one I don't even
flush it some people use their foot to
flush it that's insane
I'm not flushing your duty with my foot
but like it's ancient Rome or something
but what he would do what small would do
is he would go get in the stall and then
duty on top of someone else's duty
that's like I don't know how that I kind
of know that what the psyche behind that
is but just the level of and I remember
when I come out of the restroom he did
ask me if I flushed you know I'd be like
dang dude what get it leave me alone
he's sick little bastard bruh and then
he'd [ __ ] run up your leg or
something you know he's just smiling his
guy was he wouldn't run up your leg but
he could have if he start if he got a
good you know maybe a 40 foot start and
if you kind of put like a if you you
know put a wedge or something at the
edge of you're at the intersection of
the grounding your legs like a curve or
something a little bit of them I don't
know what that's cold but um but yeah
that's crazy dude just to think that and
just but I'm saying we're all different
people man you know some people just go
urinate in the bathroom and do that and
some people go in the bathroom and they
see
that someone else is already number two
to toilet and they go and make it a four
bro and that's that's the dark arts
brother if you wonder what the dark arts
are and stop wondering if you have a
piece of paper and somebody gave you a
test and says whatever the dark arts
that's that's it man
that's it uh let's take this call will
do one more man gang here I got a job
today I got hired gang baby you heard
that it's tough times right now it's
tough times right now people losing
their job and getting furloughed and
unloaded and we got a man right here a
caller saying he got an opportunity
brother gang man um it's like 50 miles
over and I'm not driving lately so I've
liked about 60 miles okay that 60 mile
biker do you showing up gang [ __ ] baby
just for the sign holding job and he
heard me said he wants me to come help
in the tire shop - so that's turning
into like a job job I know I was
struggling right now and wanted to tell
someone the good news and I'm dehydrated
as hell um in itself like Lauren but um
pretty decent neighborhood and we'll see
what happens is not really my experience
and the tire shop were more into doing
like construction and still trades and
stuff but oh yeah wall skills and
everything typing all work hey I'll take
what I can get right now and so I hope
you're doing it right oh man that's
awesome that's awesome man and I'm gonna
be happy for your opportunity that's
what I'm gonna do you know uh thank you
for sharing that with us man and I wish
you the best of luck with that new job
you get in there though and you'd be the
best sign tired
you do whatever you do whatever you got
to do man you know we all have we have a
lot of blessings I know a lot of people
out there struggling and uh and I know a
lot of people are worried about where
their next work is gonna come from and
their next check and and and I know that
it you know at times when we are poor in
our fiscal outlook that it's really hard
not to let that affect how we look at
ourselves and our the energy or the love
or the compassion and stuff that we you
know how rich we are inside of ourselves
you know but you know I just you know I
just you know I hope that everyone just
does what they can to keep the keep the
wealth up in their attitude and in their
compassion and in their grace for others
you know because that's
can control and I know it's hard and I'm
not saying that I know anybody's plight
or I know I know what people struggles
are like but I do know that on days when
I've had money in my bank in days when
I've had none that I'd trade both of
those away to be to have had a full
spirit you know in relief to just have
had you know to man when you win your
heart is full and you're recognizing the
things around you that are that are
keeping you up manners don't matter I'm
not looking at my bank statement then
you know so I don't know what I'm saying
I'm just I'll just hope everybody finds
as much gratitude as they can right now
and and even if the war even if the the
society that we live in and in our
financial levels aren't exactly what we
want and we don't know what our outlook
is we don't know that that we keep the
levels that we can control as high as we
can you know and I think we do that by
thinking of others by caring about
others and by trying to stagers trying
to staying in some gratitude and I'm not
telling anybody what to do I'm telling
myself what to do as well you know I
want to be a good leader I want to be a
good leader for myself oh and I think I
can and I think there's a lot of bright
I think there's a lot of bright stuff on
the horizon and I you know and I love
you you know whoever you are and a lot
of people do and a lot of people have
and you whatever if you're struggling
with something man you'll get through it
you know
thank you there's a lot of a lot of
amazing people calling on this show and
making this show awesome and people call
him from around the world
thank you you know I'm so you know I'm
so fortunate to be able to be part of a
nice group like this you know when I
think about even this all the places I
went the different cities and just
around the freaking world man and people
came out and uh and just so being loved
man [ __ ] was you know and I got so
rattled over the past year I've been hot
it's just been so hard for me to connect
with myself or just even know what was
going on but you know I'm happy today to
I'm just happy to be here and have
memories of people that care about me
and a lot of those people are a lot of
people that listen to this and in some
in really close ways in my life and
others and in and not as close ways but
still all very important and uh and yeah
let's see what we can do huh and let's
see what we can do together a member uh
gang [ __ ] sorry about the profanity
sometimes it happens you know it's that
kind of night and you know what I'll be
honest with you Brahma but to go give me
a dying cheeseburger dog from McDaniels
dog I'm about to get oh and here's what
you don't know about McDaniels is if you
go in there tell them you want a double
hamburger and they have it behind the
counter they have them they don't have
them on the sign you won't see a picture
of them maybe you'll see somebody
secretly did a drawing or something
that's the best you could get but you
order that double HB from your boy
freaking Ronnie Mac dead and they're
gonna serve that sucker to your son
so that's a little treat for you
I hope whatever you're doing that you're
finding the energy to make it as fun as
possible for you and for the
ones around you you know uh I don't know
I guess I just know a lot of people are
struggling I know a lot of people are
worried and a lot of people and and um
[Music]
yeah
I don't know I guess I just wish there
was more that I could do to help and I
know a lot of people feel that way so
just know whoever you are that people
care about you just know that and that
they always have to I bet alright I hope
you guys be good to yourselves we're
gonna leave out today on this is a song
by this man evan Bartels and you know he
he made a song years ago the devil God
and me which I love so much man and him
believe he's out of Nebraska he lives in
Nashville now and man his album he has a
CP Promised Land
that if you want to support something
that's something to go support and we'll
put the link right below you go buy it
it's 5 songs and this is one that I just
absolutely love it is called a thousand
times you guys be good to yourselves man
and I'm gonna try to do the same and we
deserve it ok
[Music]
sit here and listen to this one with you
Promised Land but Evan Bartels
a thousand times it's called
I could see the rain come from 100 miles
away baptising empty sky land with the
better days then I tell myself this will
be fine
then I watch you from
[Music]
my my
I
[Music]
it's walkie will fall from time
every time
[Music]
just a child
time for
you do
[Music]
in Istanbul Oh
g40
[Applause]
[Music]
ain't worth it
cause you so I
[Applause]
we can
[Music]
to the fire
[Applause]
[Music]
until
this'll be fine
[Music]
[Applause]
it was easy
I wish i
[Music]
she was
I wish I have
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
why
you die
[Music]
you
Canberra